this man who came out with 200 yards
receiving
at the tight end spot not just for the
raiders but for everybody's fantasy
league teams in this studio we all
love this man and we all want to say
thank you personally to uh
the pro bowl tight end of your las vegas
raiders darren waller how are you darren
i'm doing good rich how you doing i'm
doing better for you
how about that so
thank you essentially i don't usually
start a interview saying thank you but
uh
i'll start this one thank you um so
let's get into this um you're where were
you on the field when
uh derek went up top to rugs at the very
end
uh i was in i was in pass protection i
was uh
i'm supposed to be like chipping and
running like a like a check down route
for derek but he called me into
like extra protection for uh the blitz
that the jets were dialing up so i was
pass protecting so i saw the entire
flight of the ball from derek's hand to
jerry okay so um
you knew the blitz was coming huh darren
yeah yeah why
um i mean i see it as uh i mean that's
what uh
greg williams likes to do and that's
what uh the
the jets do best they've been doing well
getting home with pressure
in our game and in the prior week so i i
guess they just wanted to stick to what
they thought was most effective
uh that's what i think the reasoning
behind it is i guess but uh i mean we
just go
we just do what the defense gives us so
uh in your
days of playing football darren
uh i assume you've been in a position
like this before where you need to
hit a big one in order to win with very
little time left have you ever been in a
position
where uh a team has blitzed like that
darren um i don't think so no
so this is the first essentially yeah
yeah
okay now did they blitz the the play
before too the one up top to agalor that
was uh potentially
the game-winner did they blitz um
nah that was uh they just dropped into
uh into cover two on that one
because we ran like a that was a play to
beat a cover two because
their stadiums like to jump that deep
out route and nelson ran a double move
so he got
uh behind there but that was like like a
soft zone
okay so uh after the game um
were you all just getting together
saying i can't believe they blitzed us
did that happen um i think more guys
were just more happy that we won
yes and uh just like the emotion was so
high it wasn't just like a
why they blitzed us like later on it was
just kind of like they blitzed so we
took advantage but it was like initially
it was just like
you know just crazy emotion so let's get
into that the last two weeks it's been
quite a struggle compared to the
the previous 10 darren do you think that
whatever
was going on with the team traveling to
the east coast and back to back weeks
can't be simple for that playing early
window games you through that and now
you're ready for the last four weeks
essentially what did happen the last two
weeks is my way of asking that
um you know just not uh
playing our best football um you know
mistakes being made not you know being
as precise as we usually are
um i'll say uh our run game wasn't
there like we know it can be like it
usually is and that's just you know
that's where i run first team
so that kind of sets the tone but um but
yeah it's good to have
survived that trip i mean um came out
with the win and now it's like we still
have
you know things that we want in front of
us so it's good to be at home and
have three of the last four here and to
be able to you know be in a situation
that
uh serves an advantage to us darren
waller tied into the las vegas raiders
here on the rich eisen show
um your story's amazing darren what you
are
who you are what you are what you've
become where you've been
where you're going what you've got going
for you is truly remarkable i honestly
did not know your story until
hard knocks last year if i had told that
kid
from the baltimore ravens what's going
on right now for you what would you have
said
um i mean
it was i mean you know everything was
going on back then but it was just like
you know i tried to do it all myself
without any help without uh
you know any kind of guidance um but now
it's like
you know looking back i was just you
know trying to just
impress so many people and me all things
to all people and now it's just like
a much more simpler life and the things
that i do are uh
are pleasing to god and pleasing to me
so it's i just
it's just a much more simple way of
living than before like i felt like i
had to
do so many different things whereas now
i can just focus on what i got to do
well there's so many people who are
listening and watching right now who
know somebody or perhaps
are battling addiction like you did
darren how did you
turn the corner how did you plant your
foot and say this is
this is going to stop and i'm going to
go in a different direction how did you
do it
um i mean it starts with like you know
admitting
like that you're basically like
powerless but you don't really have
as much control over you know
what you think you have control over and
admitting that and realizing that you
need help and that you can't do it alone
and you know just getting transparent
and honest
with yourself to the point that it hurts
but after that initial pain
comes freedom and you know hope for your
future whereas it was all clouded by
you know darkness and negativity before
but you got to be honest with yourself
because i mean
the drugs and alcohol really just
symptom of what's really going on inside
you inside your mind inside your spirit
so it's just
you know confronting those things and
then the sky's the limit after that
well the sky is certainly still the
limit for you i i mean
to what do you attribute your success on
the field
um i mean i just attributed to just the
way that i've
you know built a new foundation for my
life since you know that time i had to
be
out of the league and just allowed me to
you know
reorganize my priorities and realize
that you know
my mental health and my you know
spiritual life
are need to be intact those have to be
my priorities in order for
the products in the football field to be
there like i have to take
myself onto the field i can't just turn
into a new person like who i am is going
to be out there on display
with that helmet on and pads on so i
make sure that i'm in check and that i'm
doing the work and you know not trying
to attach myself to results and outcomes
and just you know just
losing myself in the process who is
who's your safety net right now who is
your
support team who's your family friends
uh
walk me through it darren waller who
who's there with you for you
yeah i got my parents uh i got
you know my best friend i got uh you
know
men in recovery that are the same
journey that i'm in that i look to for
advice and
guidance on a day-to-day basis um you
know my teammates got my back
my my position coach uh frank smith
definitely has my back
um just me as a person so i got a lot of
people invested in me
just darren wall and not just you know
to tie in that's out there making plays
it's just
you know they love me for me and you
know invest a lot of time and energy
into me and i'm just thankful to them
for that
what is it like to have jason whitten as
a teammate at this part of your life and
career
i mean a goat i mean that's a first
ballot hoffer
that is lining up with you and in your
room what has he been like to be around
with you for you um it's been an
incredible experience
um you know i saw everyone i've never
met someone that's so intense about the
smallest details of the game
and just seeing how he knows like
everything
that everyone is doing on the offense
and it's not just like
from him it's like i'm learning like
okay i can't just learn my position or
learn my responsibility i need to learn
where i fit in the big picture and how
all these little details one you know
false step or one
you know inch can make a difference in a
play and just seeing how passionate he
is about that
and how that can turn into you know you
know just having that advantage when you
go out there so you can just
you know with a guy that doesn't even
have like
the freakish athleticism can literally
like be the best in the league for
almost two decades so it's just like a
tribute to you know just him
and you know he's also super funny too
and just brings like a light personality
he knows when to
be demanding when to be aggressive and
also when to be light-hearted so it's
just
honestly amazing so you who has an
incredible physical gift
um you you are now you say more aware
of uh what x y and z is doing and what
derek carr
needs to look at where you are in the
grand scheme of things
you're you're more aware of that thanks
to whitten in a way yeah i know like
when
when um you know when derek would be
delivering me the ball if i'm
say i'm third in the progression like i
know that okay like there's no reason
for me to rush this route or
not get to my death maybe i can get a
yard deeper just so i know that i'm in
that window at the right time
and then running the run game as well
just knowing you know with the calls
that the center's making and who
those like the center and the guard are
comboing to and so i can kind of
learn those calls and like okay i'm
going to this guy so if it's like
in the heat of the moment um you know
they shift or something i can know in my
mind i don't need someone else to tell
me
but i can you know communicate that to
other guys and know myself what's going
on so it's just like
super a big advantage okay so speaking
on behalf of all
fantasy football folks who have you on
their team including everyone here in
studio
please don't tell me you're a third in
the progression ever again don't tell me
okay darren that's not true right that's
you just you just said that make ways
man
i understand we've got great balance but
sometimes sometimes i am uh
you know sometimes i'm not no hold on a
second less often right i mean don't you
know
i i need to make sure everything's okay
darren you know what i mean
i know there's no eye on darren or
waller but i need to make sure that
you're
i mean these are the playoffs i know
you've got you got four weeks to go for
your playoffs but these are our playoffs
darren i gotta be honest with you
if you really want to make that be 100
sure you could have one jonathan
you know i would get he hasn't been on
since he's become the coach i mean you
know i
i do wear my my ffca shirts and
and visors around at home you know that
he that he sent here but i
so just you do i can i can go through
mayhawk though you know i work with him
for a very long time darren
i can go through oh yeah yeah there you
go you got the plug okay yeah
accesso i just don't know how mayok
would handle it if i asked mike about my
fantasy team i don't think he would uh
he would endeavor that question he might
have ever thank you
no he might understand he might
understand give me your favorite
grudenism
give me your favorite phrase that you
never heard before until it came out of
gruden's mouth
can you do that you got one for me darin
oh man i know uh
when he's uh if somebody's like
you know forcing something yeah um
he'll say uh don't shove sandal please
don't shove santa before he's he's
before he's asked is that what you said
don't
don't shove sand up a fleas
don't shove that was the worst game of
telephone
ever don't shove sand up a fleas yeah
i've never heard that knock on wood if
you're with me guys have you heard that
one before i haven't heard that
one brand new tell me about your
foundation how we can get involved
darren
the floor is yours please um yeah darren
waller foundation
um he's based in las vegas uh really
just trying to target
you know youth and get in front of them
and then explain to them what can
happen if you choose to go the route of
you know using drugs and alcohol to cope
or to fit in and
just have a good time like just put my
story out there to let them know that
you know it's not a route that you want
to take if you really you know are
connected with who you are and
you know your creative talents and you
know just you know where you really want
to be in life so just giving them
outlets and encouraging like you know
meditation
um finding a creative outlet whether
it's music art or something like that
but it's really just education and then
you know working towards funding
treatment for people
because i know that you know the
facility leaks at me too was
you know crazy expensive but i never
like but the fact that i was able to get
an upgraded
um program of recovery that that that
helped me so i want to do that for
somebody else
so it's really just you know educating
and then really like getting these
people into the places that they need
for
the help that they need at darren waller
fdn
on twitter uh your instagram is
rackquall
right did i get that right is that right
yeah ragwall with 2ks on rack
okay did somebody just laugh in the
background with me saying that did that
did i just hear that
did somebody yeah who's who's laughing
at me
darren who is that is that it's mayotte
i got uh i've
have a friend living with me okay i know
i i know i'm a 51 year old white man i
get it you know i'm just
you know i've just i you know you tell
your friend to back off and leave you
alone because you're first in our
progression okay darren
you got it okay
yes sir thanks for the call like i said
i i really
um uh i'm i'm a fan man uh what you've
been
uh through and what you have created for
yourself
is truly an inspiration it really is
darren and i know you might think about
that every now and then and
uh if that brings you any ounce of
pressure please know
how many people you're affecting and and
remove that from your world and just
keep falling out
okay appreciate you racing me good luck
right back at you thank you darren
waller you keep doing what you're doing
that's darren waller right here on the
rich eisen show did i should i say
ragwall is that what i should say or
i'm not sure but that was funny
i heard somebody laugh somebody laughed
yeah
what happened what's that all about hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here